các bạn phải có điểm hòa dựng kênh của những năm trước rồi
cái này là chứ sẽ của những năm trước khi năm nay chúng ta khóc có thể biết được
thì đều đó phải là 1 tham từ 2 vi bống điểm chẳng lời
thì các bạn mới có khả năng chúng tựa thằng nài
hay là năng phải chính thân hành hay hóa chí cinh gân
thì đều đó các bạn cũng nói từ 2 vi bà điểm chẳng lời
thì mới bạn có khả năng chúng tựa thằng nài
tôi gên các bạn cần lỗi đây là những điểm
để chúng ta chảy màng tính trước tham khả của mà thôi
theo bắt thường về của bỏ với dụng vào tạo thị chúng ta sẽ có phần vui đợi bắt thường về rồi
bỏ với dụng vào tạo thị chúng ta sẽ có phần vào tạo thị chúng ta sẽ có phần vui đợi bắt thường về rồi